duro revés para el gobierno peronista de
alberto fernández en las primarias que
muestran su derrota en 18 de los 24
distritos del país incluyendo a buenos
aires bastión histórico del peronismo y
encargado del 40 por ciento de los votos
nacionales el resultado es el primer
balance de la gestión del mandatario
desde su elección en diciembre de 2019 y
evidentemente
algo no habremos hecho bien para que la
gente no nos acompañe como esperamos que
nos acompañen
y todo lo que estamos aquí escuchamos el
veredicto de la gente lo escuchamos con
respeto pero con mucha atención y es que
la recesión económica en argentina
arrastrada desde 2018 con el aumento del
índice de pobreza hasta el 42 por ciento
también ha pasado factura al ejecutivo
de fernández un problema que se sumó a
la pandemia a su gestión ya las
impopulares restricciones junto a
escándalos como la fiesta de cumpleaños
de fabiola yáñez esposa del presidente
en pleno confinamiento creo que hubo un
mal manejo de la pandemia se realizaron
de golpe un montón de meses y después
la gente seguro igual trabajaba
de momento la ventaja en estas primarias
que definen quién tendrá más
posibilidades de ganarse un asiento en
el congreso en los comicios del 14 de
noviembre es para la coalición opositora
juntos por el cambio pero con dos meses
por delante el presidente aseguró
conserva la esperanza y prometió
revertir los resultados